kenisha is asked to subtract seven v
squared minus five b plus one from two b
squared plus three b plus eleven her
work is shown below and we see all the
steps that she took and then they say at
which step did khanisha make an error
and it's pretty clear she made an error
because they're not giving us an option
that she didn't make an error so let's
see what went on here so the first thing
is we we want to subtract 7b squared
minus 5b plus 1. we want to subtract
that from 2b squared plus 3b plus 11.
and we see then step one she set it up
properly she is indeed subtracting
she is indeed subtracting 7b squared
minus 5b plus 1 from
2b squared plus 3b plus 11. that's fair
all right so step one seems to be okay
now let's see step two it looks like
she's going to distribute the negative
sign so nega the negative of 7b squared
is i usually say negative 7b squared
we're going to subtract 7b squared and
then you have the negative
of negative 5b
well that's going to be positive 5b so
this right over here this one over here
should
this over here should be a positive 5b
let me do that in a new color
so this should be a positive 5b
and then the negative of positive 1 this
should be a negative one that should be
a negative one right over there so she's
making a mistake she's making a mistake
in step two when she distributes this
negative sign
so step two is where she made
is where she actually made her error
from there it seems reasonable she is
subtracting the coefficients on the b
squared terms so 2b squared minus 7b
squared it gets us this right over there
then on the b terms you have 3b
and then let's see
you have it should be 3b plus 5b if you
distributed the negative sign right but
since she didn't distribute the negative
sign right she has 3b minus 5b
and it should be 11 minus 1 but since
she didn't do the distribution correctly
we have 11 she has it should be 11 minus
1 as we said before because you're going
to distribute this negative sign but she
left that as a plus 1 and so that's why
she got that over there so her real
mistake was clearly in step 2 because
from there on she's doing reasonable
things it's just she made that one error